in this country March Madness got into a
full frenzy yesterday and quickly lived
up to the hype and there were some major
upsets although the winning teams didn't
seem too upset about it Jan Crawford is
here with a recap of yesterday's action
and there was a lot of it Jan what's up
you know I mean we're just getting
started Nate and we are seeing it is
called March Madness for a reason you
had college hoops things I mean up
ending brackets across the country in
fact of the millions of brackets that
people submitted there are so few
remaining only close to 800 perfect ones
off the window for the lead it was a
roar heard around the country
Princeton grow their way
into round two 15 seed Princeton took
down the heavily favored Arizona
Wildcats the ivy league Underdog busting
brackets from coast to coast
but the Tigers weren't the days only
Cinderella
his Madness reared its head early
services in its first appearance in the
big dance in 43 years 13 seat Furman
began its Fairy Tale run knocking off
Virginia in the tournament's first major
upset what does it make big shots I call
myself winner mere inches can separate
the winners from the losers
Number Nine West Virginia coming this
close to beating 8th ranked Maryland at
the buzzer instead they're going home
and the Terrapins are advancing
number one seed Kansas is once again
showing its Smite hoping to become the
first repeat Champion since 2007. the
top overall seed Alabama rolled over
their competition beating Texas A M
Corpus Christi by 21.
in a potential upset avoided for top
seed Houston in a late night game 16
seed Northern Kentucky tied the game
early in the second half right now
Northern Kentucky really beating Houston
at their game and Trail by only five
points with minutes left the Cougars
came out on top to advance to the next
round
[Applause]
and this afternoon the women's
tournament will tip off with South
Carolina looking to become back-to-back
Champions they're going to go in as
heavy favorites as one of the best
players in the country in the league of
Boston and they have not lost yet this
season it's going to be hard to see who
can beat them some good basketball going
on Jan Oh it's the best time of the year
except Christmas yes
is my Princeton Tigers also and I filled
out the women's bracket yes okay thank
you yesterday yes everyone you have
until 12 12 15 to get those in that's
right so if your bracket is busted I
haven't done any brackets yet so maybe I
can yeah you still have time all right
all right thank you appreciate it first
round coverage of the NCAA Men's
Basketball Tournament continues this
afternoon on CBS Sports and Warner
Brothers Discovery sports starting at 12
15 East